c'était le 31 octobre 1999 une fin
d'après midi d'automne et dans la vie de
christophe dominici quelque chose allait
changer
par la magie d'une demi finale de coupe
du monde gagnée face aux all blacks
il a qui soudain une réputation et une
dimension planétaire 1 m 73 81 kg
physiquement dominici c'est titi qui
triomphe de grosminet trois quarts aile
coincés au fond blanc il tient plus du
joyeux lutins que l'armoire à glace et
ses qualités de rugbyman sont
extraordinaires après la demi-finale
rançon de la popularité
il fut de plus en plus sollicités les
soirées les invitations à la télé et en
novembre 2000
grosse fatigue révélée par une chute de
tension de tous liés à des problèmes
personnels comme on dit pudiquement deux
mois d'arrêt ce qui ne tue pas te rend
plus fort je crois que ça
la phrase de dire ce qu'elle veut dire
c'est que j'avais besoin de souffler à
ce moment là en novembre 2000 et et
voilà quoi si vous avez obligé j'étais
obligé de me recadrer de bordeaux
naissance même but
ce que je faisais quoi après son retour
dans le tournoi des six nations
christophe dominici et s'est refait un
physique et un moral avec son club du
stade français avant d'affronter l'est
en finale de la coupe d'europe
les joueurs se sont entraînés cette
semaine sur le terrain d'evry pour les
interviews il y avait des journalistes
et des enfants très tard à 17 ans est ce
que tous les joueurs font l'âme pour le
même entraînement on s'entraîne ensemble
mais il ya une spécificité de deux
postes
quant au final c'est pour la gagner donc
vivement que toutes nos énergies soient
concentrés sur cet objectif là parce que
c'est un événement très important pour
chaque oeil et je dirais pas qu'on peut
rentrer dans l'histoire on peut marquer
et faire quelque chose de grand donc
qu'on le fasse tous ensemble
christophe dominici admet volontiers que
sans le rugby il serait devenu un voyou
originaire du var parti de pas grand
chose le voilà à paris en équipe de
france
il accomplit une carrière en lettres
capitales en quelque sorte un homme de
défis
[Musique]